folks let's face it the environment is
everywhere and we got to protect the
environment at all costs and by protect
I mean protect our right to drill it
burn it frak it flip it reverse it it's
worked like if I can plan wet now
liberals they see the environment is
something you can't touch all they care
about is polar bears I'm like guys we've
already tricked them into giving us the
Coca Cola recipe we don't need them
anymore because the environments main
purpose is to support business Trump
knows this which is why he appointed my
man
Scotty Pruett to run the Environmental
Protection Agency we shouldn't put up
fences we should we should to say we've
got this tremendous natural resource
don't touch it it's so pristine don't
touch it we should be about what
managing that natural resource exactly
managing like any good manager he's
there to take a good piece of land and
get the most money out of it it's about
time the environment got a pimp and we
got one now and one to the EPA that's a
dangerous job what are you on the right
side of history
you're gonna come under attack cNN has
learned that security for the EPA's top
official Scott Pruett was just beefed up
they're hiring more agents they're
installing new security equipment hiring
and training some 12 new agents for that
team 24/7 protection yep yeah 24/7
protection I get that it's why I sleep
with a baseball bat under my bed when my
bed is a bathtub full of knives
Scottie needs the same protection
because they're coming for him who is
they the haters protesters Democrats
enchanted spirits of the Fern Gully and
they hate scott pruett
and his well documented productivity
when he was Oklahoma's Attorney General
Pruitt joined industry groups to sue the
EPA more than a dozen times
that's a hell of a fact right there put
that on a Snapple cap and then throw
that Snapple bottle into the ocean for
the Dolphins to play with they loved
that even before joining the EPA Pruitt
was trying to liberate the environment
from its EPA shackles in fact unlinked
in scott pruett profile still says that
he is a leading advocate against the
EPA's activist agenda which technically
is still true and since Pruitt already
knows all the EPA's vulnerabilities he
doesn't need to waste any of his time
talking to bug nerds and plant dweebs
and is it CNN reported this week that
less than 1% approach meetings are with
environmental groups now you and I know
that CNN is fake news but sometimes they
report news that I like and that means
it's real Chuck throw the chart up god
oh I love this chart right here at the
top the majority of Pruitt's meetings
are with industry stakeholders like
fossil fuels manufacturing and mining
and down here this little sliver that's
environmental groups which get fewer
meetings with Pruit than miscellaneous
which which by the way / Pruitt that's
mostly the 15 minutes he takes every day
to pour a bunch of tiny water bottles
down the sink now if anyone at home is
not hydrating your sink you got to start
hydrating your sink it's not just Pro it
you could see the EPA changing all over
from staffing to their positions on
which chemicals can kill you the United
States for decades has struggled to
properly regulate chemicals there was a
struggle that's played out in the since
the start of the Trump administration in
which the career people that have worked
there at they were being overridden by
the new appointees and these new
appointees in a number of cases had come
from the chemical industry itself yes
more foxes in the hen house to be fair
it's basically a fox house at this point
with a couple of traumatized chickens in
the corner just waiting to get managed
ants and here with the New York Times
which is made out of dead trees
hypocrites when the New York Times
emailed the EPA asking about why some of
these chemicals had been deregulated the
EPA snapped back with no matter how much
information we give you you would never
write a fair piece
the only thing inappropriate and biased
is you continued fixation on writing
elitist clickbait trying to attack
qualified professionals committed to
serving their country Oh New York Times
you just got burned worse than Eric
Trump in four minutes of sunlight I know
by the way Eric
buddy you and I us porcelain men we
gotta use SPF 50 or higher dodging later
bro
but the hater left is still hate coming
after our epa chief with everything they
got luckily Scott's got a secret weapon
Scott Pruett is spending $25,000 in
taxpayer money your money to build a
cone of silence at his agency a
soundproof room where he can make phone
calls or have meetings a cone of silence
was the only ice cream I was allowed to
order as a child
Scott needs this soundproof booth with
that many meetings on your schedule you
gotta focus otherwise outside forces
will pollute your opinion he's
protecting the environment his own
environment and this booth will help
keep him and his ideas safe and we need
to keep him safe because guys he's the
only Scott Pruett we got and we all
share him once he's gone he's gone
probably into lobbying somewhere so he
can't take enough precautions over
something so precious and rare he's
protecting business which is the one
natural resource that America can't live
without it's that
for the full thing is ridiculous bill
night you're not supposed to be out here
until act 3 I made that very clear I
originally came out here to complain
about well to complain about the whole
show in general but then I heard this
EPA stuff Jordan the environment is
being irreversibly damaged by these
sorts of no no but no bill no I'm not
taking new information right now protect
me protect me I need protecting
yes thank you thank you go Phil no I
can't hear you I don't want your new
information
[Music]